[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous leurs du 7-8 journal
bienvenue pour cette semaine nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv 78è
les titres de ce lundi 20 novembre
clap de fin pour le festival saint
quentin la troisième édition de
l'événement dédié au documentaire s'est
achevée après cinq jours de projections
à saint-quentin-en-yvelines cérémonie de
clôture hier après-midi au ciné cette à
elancourt trois prix ont été remis
retour dans cette édition
[Musique]
elle va s'ouvrir dans un contexte social
toujours difficile la 33e campagne
d'hiver des restos du coeur débute
demain dans les yvelines près d'un
million et demi de repas ont été
distribués lors de la dernière campagne
invité de ce journal henri fall chargé
de communication aux restos du coeur des
yvelines
et puis c'était ce week end au château
de versailles environ 500 jeunes de
quartiers populaires de la région ont
participé à un grand quizz sur
l'histoire de france dans la salle des
batailles
une troisième édition tournée vers la
musique le festival saint quentin s'est
terminée hier événements du film
documentaire organisé par tv 78 après
l'ouverture mercredi à l'ugc skywest est
la cérémonie de clôture se tenait hier
au ciné c'est ta il encourt projection
et remise des prix était au programme
trois documentaires récompensé le
palmarès de feu de ce festival 2010 est
avec mélanie poker
[Musique]
le festival saint quentin s'est terminée
comme il l'a débuté en musique
une troisième édition tournée vers le
4ème art le prix des cinémas a
récompensé à l'unanimité youssef le
gambré ce documentaire s'attache un
musicien et luthier youssef sert locales
comme on le voit dans le film il habite
trappe
c'est quelqu'un qui est sur
l'immigration qui se marie kuhn
française dont contre eux on trouvait
que son parcours était vachement
intéressant vachement positif parce
qu'en fait lui il veut y arriver on a
trouvé que c'était un comment dirais-je
est un beau film en fait sur le sur le
partage sur la tolérance voilà c'est
pour ça qu'on lui a décerné le prix des
cinémas de saint quentin en yvelines
je fais un très bon je suis la
connaissance avec une visite ranger bah
ça change beaucoup pour moi
le prix tv 78 a été remis à une
réalisation suisse avec nice hand
caroline harnes et martina rider plonge
dans la tradition musicale des yéniches
un tacle semi nomades
le choix est multiple il ya le thème qui
était très original et qui n'étaient pas
connus de nous avant de visionner le
documentaire il ya le lieu il ya la
qualité des images la qualité du montage
c'est absolument évident il ya la
découverte
même si on le voit pas beaucoup mais
quand même un stephan eicher qui nous
surprend même dans son langage
[Musique]
le prix troisième revient lui à anaïs
prosaïque réalisatrice deviendra dès
l'écoutent virtuose quatrième prix dont
on n'a pas parlé dans ce sujet le prix
du public lui sera annoncé sur notre
antenne mercredi prochain porter la voix
des plus démunis la 33e campagne d'hiver
des restos du coeur s'ouvre demain
bonsoir ans les fal bon soit vous êtes
en charge notamment de la communication
au sein à des restos du coeur des
yvelines alors c'est une campagne
d'hiver qui débutent à dans une
situation difficile près de 9 millions
de personnes en france vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté
le constat est le même chaque année la
pauvreté la précarité progresse en
france mais je sais pas parler de la
france mais je sais parler des yvelines
et la pauvreté progresse doucement mais
progresse quoi on a de l'ordre de plus
de plus 3% par an de personnes qui
viennent
aux restos du coeur l'action des restos
du coeur est encore du coup tout à fait
indispensable aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est indispensable et qui en plus est
un bon outil c'est à dire que on a des
quand vous donner sens aux restos du
coeur par l'action des bénévoles partout
ce qu'on met tout autour vous arrivez à
donner six ans donc six fois plus aux
plus démunis parce qu'on fait de la
ramasse dans les grandes surfaces qu'on
fait des collectes qu'on anime et sachez
aussi que les restos du coeur c'est pas
que l'alimentaire
oui c'est une aide alimentaire mais il
ya aussi d'autres actions ont pensé vrai
à l'aide alimentaire en sept campagnes
diverses affaires aux restos du coeur
action tout le monde dit 'cela
d'alimentaire mais là déliement terre
n'est qu'un premier pas l'aide sociale
plus là on peut essayer après de
comprendre le problème de ceux plus
démunis c'est un problème de logement
sans entrain de travail c'est un
problème de formation c'est un problème
d'addiction c'est un problème est
comment l'aider à se reconstruire
il ya eu un je crois
c'était samedi à 13h30 sur tf1 il y
avait un tout à des films sur l'action
des restos du coeur et c'était très très
bien fait et on voit bien que l'action
c'est pas que donner à manger c'est
aider à se reconstruire et à la veille
de cette 33ème campagne dans les
yvelines tout et tout est prêt pour pour
bien commencer
tout est prêt tout est prêt mais il
manque encore des choses et là ce qui
manque le plus les bénévoles paris
bénévoles et voilà et alors des
bénévoles pour distribuer des boîtes de
conserve dans un centre on arrive à en
trouver et puis un actionnaire qui fait
le mardi le mercredi le troisième de
jeudi et ça va là l'endroit où vraiment
c'est à ces critiques les prisons la
sécurité dans l'entrepôt d'accord
l'entrepôt parce que d'adevia fin c'est
un métier où c'est dans le froid c'est
l'entrepôt il fait pas chaud c'est il
faut se lever de bonne heure et puis
quand même fou quand même être costauds
quoi faire il faut il faut prendre des
déboires dans une palette et même dans
une autre pour les distribuer dans nos
différentes formes de distribution
et c'est en banque de personnes et de
personnes pas jeanne quoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui la moyenne d'âge est
quand même extrêmement élevé dans ils
font bien leur travail c'est bien mais
si on peut avoir d'autres dont je veux
je m'adresse à l'appel est lancé à tous
ceux qui nous regardent si vous avez un
peu de temps libre venez nous aider à
l'entrepôt c'est aux clayes-sous-bois
alors y'a plus de 13000 personnes qui
ont été accueillies lors de la dernière
campagne des restos du coeur dans les
yvelines
c'est environ un million et demi de
repas servis
c'est tout à fait vous pensez que vous
allez ferrando russe on ne sait pas le
big de beats et saufs ont essayé de
faire le nécessaire
c'est pas on cherche pas à faire plus je
vais pas dans le domaine du du business
où on veut faire un chiffre d'affaires
le plus élevé possible ses voisins b
ce qu'on voudrait faire c'est faire une
plus de continuité d envoyer la campagne
d'hiver
autrefois il y avait que la compagnie va
maintenant on fait la campagne d'été ont
fait une intercampagne en vaudrait que
l'aide soit continu vis-à-vis des plus
démunis et qui ait pas de rupture dans
notre aide
voilà alors les produits alimentaires
que vous distribuez ce que c'est on est
plutôt sur des produits achetés par par
votre fédération à les yvelines où c'est
les produits collectés quand commencer
comment ça c'est on est on est assez en
avance dans les yvelines pour essayer de
trouver des ressources locales par
rapport à des produits achetés par le ce
qu'on appelle le national d'accord parce
que c'est nationale qui achètent parce
qu'ils arrivent à avoir acheté des
quantités tels qu'ils ont des prix
défiant toute concurrence donc
aujourd'hui voyez c'est 60% qui est
acheté par le national mais 40% qui est
trouver localement par des collectes par
des ramasse par les centres des grandes
distributions qui nous donnent des
produits par des collèges des lycées
une prof qui fait un thème sur le resto
du coeur et puis il faut une collègue
qui arrive à ramener 2 3 4 cadix et
c'est fantastique
alors on plus de 1000 mhz et bénévoles
sur les yvelines pour cette campagne qui
seront donc mobilisés
comment on commença va s'organiser
concrètement c'est à dire que là ça a
déjà commencé j'imagine en amont des
dans les centres de tri ça va être
dispatchés ensuite dia il il ya la
partie logistique de trouver trouver les
matières premières et les acheminer
jusqu'au sang de distribution mais il ya
toute la partie aussi inscriptions pour
toutes les personnes d'une fois pour
rester au du coeur vous êtes
il faut vous inscrire il faut montrer
vos papiers quels sont vos ressources
combien et on fait ça dans ce mois de
novembre et ensuite vous avez une carte
et vous pouvez venir toutes les semaines
chercher de la marchandise donc il ya
des deux actions parallèles vers les
bénéficiaires pour les inscrire et vers
les acheteurs et les entrepôts pour
fournir dernière minute de cet entretien
la veille de cette 33ème campagne
d'hiver qu'est qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter à vous restos du coeur des
yvelines ben nous souhaiter des
bénévoles qu'ils soient actifs
et puis une pouvoir accueillir aussi
bien qu'on peut tous nos bénéficiaires
voilà qui est une sorte d'osmose foyers
entre nos bénévoles et de bénéficiaires
pour clore avec l'autre on arrive à
remonter les pentes qui ont été
descendus et je précise en ont parlé
tout à l'heure des besoins en bénévoles
précise que vous pouvez devenir bénévole
ou également faire un don aux restos du
coeur sur le site internet qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran merci henri fall
d'avoir été avec nous merci beaucoup
fait en charge de la communication et
notamment aux restos du coeur des
yvelines dans l'actualité aussi le
premier salon de la rénovation
énergétique de saint quentin en yvelines
il s'est déroulé hier à la ferme du
manet de montigny le bretonneux
objectif découvrir toutes les étapes
nécessaires à la rénovation de son
habitat pour le rendre plus économes en
énergie et à magny les hameaux les
propriétaires d'une maison
rénové et économes ont ouvert leurs
portes aux participants mélanie poquet
et aux rayures aux panneaux
photovoltaïques pompes à chaleur cette
maison en ossature bois situé à magny
les hameaux et lauréate d'un concours
organisé en 2014 par l' agence locale de
l'énergie et du climat de saint quentin
en yvelines
sa particularité elle est économe l'idée
c'est vraiment de de consommer le moins
d'énergie et en plus ils produisent de
l'énergie grâce aux panneaux solaires
photovoltaïques une production
énergétique qui permet aux propriétaires
de payer leur facture annuelle
d'électricité depuis 30 ans ils ont
multiplié les aménagements pour rénover
leur habitat isolation changement des
fenêtres et installation d'une pompe à
chaleur il y a trois ans montant des
travaux
80000 euros un investissement qui permet
avant tout d'améliorer leur confort où
on a fait ça pourra pour vraiment
comment en termes de d'économies mais
surtout un confort de chauffe qui est
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus intéressant
que les chauffages électriques
traditionnels une maison que les
particuliers ont pu découvrir à
l'occasion du premier salon de la
rénovation énergétique objectifs de
l'événement découvrir tous les acteurs
du secteur présents sur notre territoire
c'est important pour mettre concrètement
des visages derrière des métiers et puis
découvrir un petit peu ce que c'est
puisque l'idée aussi de la plateforme
c2c de rassembler tous les acteurs de la
rénovation énergétique et dans les
acteurs il ya autant ceux qui font les
travaux que les maîtres d'ouvragé en
2017 sur le territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines 90 propriétaire à faibles
ressources ont reçu une aide pour
rénover leur habitat ronnement question
à magny les hameaux une partie du viaduc
de la ligne 18 doit passer d'ici à 2030
ce tronçon en aérien de 13 km est prévue
sur le plateau de saclay pour relier
versailles à l'aéroport d'orly une
enquête publique sur le sujet est lancé
jusqu'au 20 décembre à magny les hameaux
et à châteaufort ces communes espèrent
que leurs habitants feront entendre leur
voix sur le projet le
de magny-les-hameaux bertrand ou lyon
voudrait lui que le viaduc se transforme
en souterrain il était l'invité du 7-8
l'hebdo c'est un investissement pour
cent ans on ne peut pas se permettre de
faire n'importe quoi on traverse des
paysages on passe à côté des riverains
de zones rurales là on précise que vous
évoquez vous le caillou le réduite bien
entendu et tant qu'on aura cette
solution viaduc qui va s'inscrire pour
son temps dans l'environnement auprès
des populations rurales et là ça rejoint
finalement directement la délégation que
kim est octroyée au niveau de saint
quentin en yvelines il est hors de
question d'avoir un équipement
structurant d'avenir qui polluent
directement les riverains nos paysages
et finalement l'ensemble de notre
environnement à bertrand guillon qui ne
fait pas partie de la nouvelle
association union des élus elle réclame
l'achèvement du tronçon yvelinois de la
ligne 18 dès 2024
une ascension politique fulgurante un
peu plus d'un an après sa création le
mouvement en marche est devenu le parti
présidentiel avec l'élection à des
manuels macron à l'elysée bonsoir lance
biava merci à vous d'être avec nous vous
travaillez comme collaboratrice de
député lrm des yvelines béatrice piron
vous êtes aussi auteur et vous publié
chez les éditions ovadia en marche une
histoire française ouvrage collaboratif
que vous avez initié on va en parler
dans un instant déjà revenons sur la
démarche pourquoi avoir eu envie de
raconter cette histoire l'histoire dans
marche parce que je pense que c'est une
grande odyssée humaine c'est un
renouveau politique hors norme avec un
homme candidat devenu président de la
république qui est absolument que vous
l'avez vous l'avez dit a connu une
nation une ascension fulgurante et je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui est aussi
hors norme et je trouvais j'ai tout de
suite senti jeu
je suis moi en marche j'ai rejoint en
marche en mai 2016 vous êtes également
une détente facile me tente pas
forcément la plus la plus je suis une
des plus ardentes
mais je ne suis pas une de celles qui a
forcément le plus tracté sur les marchés
etc
je n'ai même pas réussi à monter mon
comité local en revanche je suis allé à
un certain nombre de meetings et j'ai
effectivement toujours tenu à
accompagner mon engagement militant
c'est le premier pour moi d'un
engagement littéraire
voilà je suis écrivain depuis une
dizaine d'années c'est mon sixième livre
et je trouvais que c'était intéressant
de rendre compte sur un plan littéraire
de faire participer dans un souci
d'altérité permanent dans un souci
d'unité permanente de faire participer
d'autres marcheurs avec moi donc en
vérité 30 personnes là il ya quarante
marcheurs l'assaut du mans voilà
quarante marcheurs donc je trouvais je
trouvais que c'était intéressant des dès
l'es3 moment les trois étapes du
diagnostic par lesquels on a réellement
commencé je trouvais que c'était
judicieux de rendre compte de ce qui
allait advenir parce que j'ai senti que
c'est quelque chose qui monte en
puissance savez quand on fait 22,8
innoncents on sent que ça monte en
puissance et je suis devenu ami avec un
certain nombre de marcheurs et sur les
réseaux sociaux on collecte c'est un
contrat collectif est en fait j'ai
demandé à chacun c'est très libre c'est
même un petit peu désordonné ça ce que
j'espère à 40 mans sait pas c'est pas
difficile
en fait j'ai demandé c'est pour ça que
ce n'est que parce que les gens me
disent et un collectivement ça n'a rien
à voir ce n'est pas du tout un collectif
chacun a signé son propre texte
certaines personnes ont voulu y vont ou
ont voulu y revenir plusieurs fois dont
ponctuellement il ya des gens
extrêmement passionné et qui sont aussi
riche intellectuellement qui ont voulu
qu'ils ont voulu
tout simplement témoigner et écrire leur
histoire dans marche avec emmanuel
maintenant alors il ya certaines
personnes que j'ai rencontrées sur les
réseaux sociaux que j'ai finalement du
mythe du temps aussi à voir de visu
parce que je n'ai pas non plus
rencontrer les gens tout de suite et a
beaucoup dit vinoy par la force des
choses parce que je suis désuni france
n'est jamais autant qui n'est jamais
autant parcouru aussi on département que
depuis que depuis mai 2007 entre
parenthèses mais à travers ces
témoignages que vous avez récolté
l'ascension fulgurante finalement on
explique comment parce que lassant on
l'a 62 on la sent dans les discours on
la sent il ya une teneur une véracité
une teneur intellectuelle qui est assez
impressionnante mais j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour les manuels maintenant
je ne le cache pas
et puis et puis il y a il ya tout un
programme qui c'est dicté qui se répète
aussi qu'il ya quelque chose qui se
reproduit c'est inhérent cetc sens arras
et sans arrêt à chaque fois c'est
qu'elle veut dire on avance d'un pas on
monte on monte on monte on marche on
marche en marche marche et je trouvais
que c'était c'est ça qui est important
c'est cette espèce de puissance cette
force de frappe aussi je crois que ça se
sent dans le livre ce livre est sorti
tout récemment au même moment finalement
la semaine dernière c'était cette
actualité 100 marcheurs qui avait décidé
de quitter le mouvement est ce que on
n'est pas dans un recul ou on a recul du
mouvement est ce que ce livre elle n'a
pas vocation à redonner peut-être un
second souffle
c'est un livre politique les 100
marcheurs très honnêtement je suis ça de
très très loin je trouve que je ne suis
en aucun cas d'accord avec eux s'il ya
bien un parti démocratique c'est la
république en marche
voilà chacun chacun gère avec ses 100
marcheurs oui je crois absolument pas gg
je veux pas rentrer je ne suis pas là
pour débattre les polémiques et je
respecte les opinions de chacun vous me
posiez la question est ce que ce livre a
vocation à devait finalement un nouveau
souffle déjà bas vous il ya beaucoup je
trouve qu'on est en plein dedans enfin
nouveau souffle nom n'est pas non on est
en plein dedans justement donc c'est
quelque chose qui dont on ne va jamais
cessé de parler et il ya énormément de
livres 1 sur emmanuel maintenant il a
peut-être au moins 10 12 d'art question
il nous reste un peu moins d'une minute
l'idée c'est vrai que ça soit un
véritable témoin finalement d'un pan de
l'histoire française c'est déjà un pan
de l'histoire française du coup c'est
cette ascension ouais et j'ai
personnellement en tant qu'écrivain je
n'ai jamais je ne suis pas journaliste
je ne suis pas éditoriale et je ne suis
en aucun cas historienne mais j'ai bien
l'intention de suivre ce président de la
république exceptionnel durant tout le
long de son quinquennat
je dis à tout le monde qu'il s'agit d'un
tome 1 en effet c'est un thomas y va
maintenant il va y avoir deux
participeront 780 personnes pour le tome
2 on va couvrir alors là je revois toute
la ligne éditoriale parce qu'il faut que
je serai de nouveau donc septembre 2007
en 2018
et on y reviendra et on en reparlera
toujours et ce livre je le rappelle vous
le publiez donc aux éditions ovadia en
marche
histoire une histoire française dont qui
était sorti tout récemment en libre et
vous pouvez retrouver toutes les
informations sur le site internet des
éditions ovadia la semaine dernière le
théâtre du chesnay accueillait la 17e
journée pédagogique des professions du
chiffre elle présentait les métiers de
la filière et d'experts comptables et de
commissaires aux comptes aux professeurs
et aux élèves de l'académie de
versailles
un secteur qui embauche aurélie rosé
marie pannetrat
en france 250 mille experts comptables
et pourtant ce métier est encore mal
connue casser les préjugés de cette
profession c'était tout l'enjeu de cette
journée destinée aux élèves de lycées et
de bts
on entend toujours que bâle comptable
c'est celui qui est pas beau qu'un pull
horrible avec sa calculette
mais bon voilà c'est une image a changé
cette image de personne réservée et qui
reste dans sa petite pièce font ça colle
pas du tout à notre profession le
salaire est attractif en moyenne un
expert comptable en début de carrière
gagne 29 mille euros bruts par an un
commissaire aux comptes 35000 euros et
le secteur ne connaît pas la crise on
recrute beaucoup les besoins au niveau
national sont de l'ordre de dix mille
personnes par an et si on regarde
simplement au niveau du département
d'île de france
on peut considérer qu'il ya à peu près
un millier de jeunes qui rejoignent au
cabinet chaque année pour faire
connaître ses atouts une convention a
été signée avec un lycée de saint
germain en laye une première en ile de
france
les élèves vont pouvoir accéder à une
base de données professionnelles
soixante dix mille documents sont à leur
disposition il ya toute la jurisprudence
si je peux utiliser ce terme là qu'ils
vont découvrir autrement qu'en classe
quand ils vont être devant leur micro
ordinateurs qui vont pouvoir aller
chercher des documents qui sont
désormais mis à leur disposition et donc
ils vont pouvoir analyser cette
jurisprudence pour des questions qui
leur seront posées plus tard des
professions du chiffre au coeur de tous
les secteurs d'activité en france les
experts comptables et les commissaires
aux comptes aide chaque jour des
millions d'entreprises
le sport le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines recevait ce
week end la crème des judokas de
l'hexagone le championnat de france
senior de 1ère division était au
programme des combats samedi et dimanche
retour sur l'événement avec mme elhady
poquet elie à rennes
shido yoshi ou encore ricky wac et le
vocabulaire des judokas a résonné tout
le week-end au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin pour l'occasion le
vélodrome s'est adapté les tatamis ont
pris place pour accueillir le
championnat de france seniors 1re
division qui a réuni près de 800
combattants le sais j'en sais pas au
troisième âge c'est les gens qui ont
gravi les échelons de mines benjamins
minimes cadets juniors seniors donc la
tronche âge 18 ans je pense c'est quand
même une première au niveau national
c'est le top
on ne peut pas monter plus aujourd'hui
est donc pour nous c'est un honneur
d'une part et puis bah on est ravis
d'accueillir toute la france par le beau
département des yvelines dans des
combats féminins et masculins dans cette
catégorie de poids différents les
judokas ont ainsi pu rencontrer de
nouveaux adversaires et tester leur
niveau
j'ai fait deux tours et voilà
malheureusement bas ça s'arrête là bon
je suis quand même content de moi j'ai
39 ans donc pouvoir faire encore les
championnats de france bah voila je fais
avec mon mari en plus donc mes filles
viennent nous supporter voilà ce ca que
du bonus un peu mal au début
bah je perds mon premier combat je suis
pas repêché derrière 17 évinois ont
combattu sur les sept tapis installés
pour l'occasion en plein coeur du
vélodrome
une transformation apprécié par les
participants c'est à savoir que sont
complètes comme ça les tapis souris et
c'est assez bien je pense que pau public
ça doit être assez assez agréable aussi
de pouvoir avoir la vue sur tous ces
sans passer par moi ça change
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines au lieu de
rencontres sportives depuis la rentrée
ne va pas s'arrêter en si bon chemin
d'ici la fin de l'année il accueillera
des compétitions de badminton et de
sports de combat et un championnat de
france qui a souri aux clubs de la
région d'île de france 93 médailles
glanées dont 9 en or
une première au château de versailles
l'ancienne demeure royale a accueilli
samedi le quiz de l'histoire de france
20 questions adressées à des enfants et
adolescents de la région l'événement
était organisé par les associations
nouvelles du vivre ensemble et force des
mixités le but pédagogique derrière
renforcer l'intérêt des jeunes à
l'histoire de france camille lambert et
marylène iapichino
top départ pour le grand quizz de
l'histoire de france 500 enfants pris
place dans la salle des batailles du
château de versailles transformée
aujourd'hui en classe géante
l'idée c'est de se montrer d'ailleurs à
ces jeunes que ce château il appartient
à tout le monde à tous les français que
tout le monde a le droit de faire
découvrir ce lieu qui est magnifique et
souvent quand on est dans un cadre aussi
magnifique on ne peut pas rester
indifférent et qu'il appartient à
l'histoire de france
et puis bien évidemment les sensibiliser
à cette histoire de france et c'est
important je vois un événement qui est
l'occasion pour les associations de
quartier de donner un objectif concret à
leur travail sur la culture avec les
jeunes
on travaille aussi sur ce qu'on appelle
les valeurs de la république et donc
l'histoire fait partie de ces valeurs on
appartient à ce pays
et donc ces jeunes aussi qui
appartiennent et donc bas l'histoire
c'est super important pour qu'ils
puissent se l'approprier
et être des acteurs aussi que cette
histoire beaucoup de concentration pour
se remémorer le nom de l'hymne national
ou encore le nombre de rois qui ont vécu
au château les questions allaient de la
plus facile à la plus difficile pour que
les plus jeunes aussi puissent s'amuser
c'est très très très bien
on a passé un bon moment on a répondu à
vos questions
et donc là on va y aller au goûter de
quoi laissé de bons souvenirs
et pourquoi pas créer des vocations on
reste à versailles avec ces images pour
refermer ce journal ce week-end le
palais des congrès accueille la deuxième
édition de la cour des métiers d'art
salon dédié au savoir faire et aux
créations
organisé par la chambre de métiers
d'artisanat de des yvelines 70
professionnels présents et notamment ini
monteyne elle crée des instruments
d'astronomie à la manière d'antan et des
propos recueillis par camille lambert
ces instruments vont permettre de se
repérer dans le temps et
géographiquement dans le temps c'est à
dire qu en mesurant la hauteur du soleil
ou des étoiles au dessus de l'horizon
on va pouvoir lire l'heure solaire des
gens seront perdantes ans et puis une
fois que on a réglé l'instrument avec
cette prise de mesures et le réglage
nous pièce qui tourne sur le dessus
d'instruments on a exactement la
configuration du ciel compta au dessus
de la tête
en fait à son amitié soutient la filière
métiers d'art déjà depuis plusieurs
années et nous souhaitions depuis
longtemps organisé un salon
il fallait trouver le lieu je les
trouvais la ville
versailles nous semblait une évidence et
plus de 5000 visiteurs se sont rendus ce
week-end à la cour des métiers d'art
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal replay
reportage à retrouver comme à
l'accoutumée sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv et 78
excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]